whatever you do you only do because God
allows you
love God
[Music]
father Gabriella amort
on the night of June 4th
[Music]
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require an
exorcism
98 I recommend him buy him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
Mort
you have a problem with me you talk to
my boss
there's a case that needs your attention
bring me the priest
I'm here to help Julia
wrong right
take cautioned their secrets buried
there
at the concealed
Church escort against this demon before
the Vatican covered it up we need to
find out why
you took the Bates
whatever you do you only do because God
allows it
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend you
my faith
does not require defense